[Musique]
les entreprises de croisière aux
baleines agace pays connaissent une
bonne saison jusqu'à présent certaines
comme les croisés à remédier aspect
remarque une hausse de la clientèle
internationale niveau touristes sur
cette année ses poteaux que durant la
pandémie si la pandémie s'est fait comme
exceptionnel mais là cette année on
retourne un peu plus à des nombres qu'on
avait avant les touristes du québec et
d'ailleurs au canada sont aussi au
rendez vous
la mère dont seront offerts instaura
bateau et on souhaite croiser la
surface alors que les visiteurs
répondent à l'appel les baleines ont
quant à elle était plus timide au cours
du dernier mois ce qui a rendu
l'observation des mammifères plus
difficile d'être l'équipe ont cherché
beaucoup tient au sort au meurtre
commençons recherche on travaille
beaucoup on
court beaucoup beaucoup noir essayer de
les rencontrer contrairement aux années
précédentes
très peu de baleines ont été observés au
large de gaspé et dans les eaux du
saint-laurent en juillet cette variation
des populations de ces mammifères est
notamment due à la recherche de
nourriture je pense que ce qui est à
retenir c'est pas que ce soit une bonne
weed mauvaise nouvelle c'est que
l'environnement dans lesquelles ces
baleines évolue à chaque année 8 20
reebok ou il varie de plus en plus de
plus en plus abruptement et ça c'est un
but qu'on a fait est ce qu on nous avait
prédit comme une des conséquences des
bouleversements climatiques les baleines
devrait être davantage présente dans les
eaux du saint-laurent en nous et en
septembre selon robert michaud ici
marguerite morin radio-canada gaspé